We're witnessing the economic and political
meltdown of Venezuela, one of South America's
most important economies.
The President of the United States doesn't
want a meltdown in Venezuela on his watch.
And that's understandable.
Unfortunately, that regime is unsustainable
today.
And a policy that encourages the democratic
opposition to have a dialogue with a repressive
regime really isn't sustainable.
The United States could be part of a process,
part of a solution to hold the Maduro government
accountable to its own constitution, and to
its commitments to defend democracy.
President Obama has an opportunity to use
diplomatic tools...
Working with key neighbors that are becoming
more active in the defense of democracy.
The President also has some unique, asymmetrical
tools that he can use to sanction individuals
within the Venezuelan regime who do not want
to see a democratic transition.
It remains to be seen whether President Obama
will be part of that solution, or whether
he'll preside over the consolidation of a
dictatorship in South America.
We all want stability in Venezuela, but at the cost of keeping a corrupt
and incompetent government in power? What do you think?
Let us know in the comments, and let us know
what other topics you want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.